welcome back to the O age you're always
welcome as you know and it's so good to
see you again you too you
[Music]
too you know this is such a complex
story you have the history of the O age
you have us striking oil that led to the
r of Terror they called it we are real
sensitive to the history that you got to
tell the story if it didn't upset people
there's something wrong something wrong
with it when this money started coming
we should have known it came with
something
else when I asked you what is your
approach you said I want to tell a story
about betrayal of trust between the O AG
people and the outside world by focusing
on Ernest and Molly it's like an analogy
of the overall situation I don't even
know if you love me anymore I am right
here
I was concerned about uh someone else
telling Art story but uh when when you
came on board you said we're going to
film here you're going to use our
language Department you were going to
work with our people who do
costumes there's no way I would have
made it without full support of the oage
community everybody was here where else
can you shoot look at this place it's
perfect we have uh different culture and
you portrayed that so well so
accurately I always think that America
needs your culture more than just
learning we could open our minds and our
hearts to a whole new
way like buzzards circling our people
we're still Warriors we're honored to
tell this powerful historical story in
the most authentic way but you sure did
that I don't know how you do it but you
sure did
it